foreign
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studio
it's the Ramsay show where America hangs
out to have a conversation about your
life and your money I'm Ramsay
personality George Campbell joined by
Jade warshaw this hour and we are taking
your calls about life money taxes
investing getting out of debt we want to
help you take the right Next Step for
your financial future the number to call
is triple eight eight two five five two
two five and it's been a fun week of
Ramsay shows so far and I say that
biasly because I was co-hosting every
single one but here's some of the crazy
calls we took there was a guy who wanted
to buy a house before he got married as
a pre-marital asset so he was
strategically trying to get this in
there before he proposed oh yeah
interesting call there I remember that
one and uh we we talked to a sweet woman
who was enabling her niece in a toxic
family situation mom was in a cult
nieces in Australia freeloading off the
ant it was a complicated one there
thanks and uh this one was a doozy Jade
we talked to a woman who was five
hundred thousand dollars in Consumer
Debt and her husband refused to work
with her uh as a team and said I'm just
resigning myself to bankruptcy
oh gosh and as someone who got out of
almost half million dollars in Consumer
Debt man I feel her pain I feel her pain
but I'm also super proud of her yeah
that was a tough one and of course uh
Christina Ellis shared her no spend
challenge that she's doing in January
and many of our audience members her her
followers on Instagram are doing that as
well have you ever done the no spend
challenge
George the first seven years of my life
with death was a no spin challenge it
wasn't a cute Trend back then no dude I
did seven and a half years of no
spending I I can't go back I Won't Go
Back you're done with that life well
it's a fun exercise of course you have
to pay your bills and all that but the
idea is to spend on no luxuries only the
Necessities to get by and it's a great
way to to advance in your financial
goals it is you can solidify those
habits I love it so hey if you miss any
of these calls any of these episodes you
can check them out on your favorite
podcasting platform and of course on our
YouTube channel be sure you catch up on
that always good times so let's get to
the phones Max joins us in Stanford
Connecticut Max welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hey George and Jade it's uh great to be
talking with you and you know pumped to
be on the show all right what's going on
max
uh so quick question
um my wife and I are actually looking
into 2023 planning our goals financially
and
um we have just moved into four five and
six so we purchased our first home back
in October so we've kind of completed
that big milestone and you know we were
at a period of time where we were just
stashing away money and trying to look
forward to the purchase and now we're in
a bit of a different mindset and we're
trying to figure out exactly where to
put our eggs in which basket we're
looking at really the home of paying
down the mortgage a bit more even though
we know we're not going to be here for
you know the long term it's not our it's
a stepping stone home for us for the
next five to seven years okay versus
putting money into amicia one and doing
that type of investing um for the next
several years
well that's a good question Max you know
you know you said you just entered into
baby steps four five and six and so
we're always going to teach for you to
walk out those baby steps in order and
when it comes to Baby Steps four five
and six you're doing them simultaneously
but you're also doing them in order by
priority so we do want to make sure that
with baby step four you're investing 15
of your income
um into mutual funds whether it's
through you know your 401k through work
or if you're doing an IRA or Roth IRA
something like that but when you have
the money left over then you can start
putting that towards the house how does
that sound to you
yeah that sounds great I mean me and my
wife we both do 15 into our raw squirrel
1ks at work okay and I guess the
question was more so like an outside
brokerage account should we start
putting dollars in there and prioritize
that versus paying down the house
knowing that we more more than likely we
won't be here as our forever home well
we won't be here on this Earth either
for forever so I I like to just think of
it this way that money that you are
paying into the mortgage is not
disappearing right you're paying it into
the equity and when you go and sell that
house seven years from now my goal for
you would be that you pay this thing off
and then you have extra money even
before you move so that would be my goal
is to pay it off when you sell it all of
that Equity gets rolled into your next
property that's right George makes a
good point your house is a force savings
account so you're not it's not like that
money's going down a you know down a
dark hole you're going to get that money
again so a great time to go beyond you
know your normal mutual funds your
normal 15 would be after you've paid
that house off right George once you get
there that is baby step seven and then
you can really start Building Wealth at
a higher rate so you can increase your
investing you can increase your giving
you can increase your spending that's
really where it becomes a Choose Your
Own Adventure but until then do 15 only
and if you max out the 401ks there are
other options you can do backdoor roths
depending on your incomes there's a lot
of other options and then if you run out
of all of those options you can move to
the brokerage account but right now I'd
be focused on paying off that house with
any extra margin you guys have you guys
have kids
no not yet just two cats all right cat
cat daddy I love it all right yeah
George is giving you great advice and uh
yeah I I would do exactly that and if
kids come into the picture then of
course you'll be looking at baby step
five as well beloved thanks for the call
Max let's move on to Angela in Canton
Ohio Angela welcome to the show
Angela are you with us
yes I'm here you got me nervous okay how
can we help today yeah it's time to cut
out all of a sudden I'm not sure what
happened there through the airwaves
question I have a question for you I
currently have an equity line at a
variable rate okay it's a small amount
of money it's like thirty three thousand
and I started to look because of rates
changing I started to look into possibly
going back into a conventional loan the
reason why I did the equity in the first
place was
um through a divorce it was my legal
obligation and it's what I could do at
the time so
I
um I can get a rate of like 5.75 going
back into a 15-year loan but the kicker
with this that I have to make the
decision on is
I had done a bad thing in the way of
co-signing for my children's cars so in
order for this to happen they have to
pay off the vehicles
or or you know basically they're going
to take that amount of money and [ __ ] it
into the mortgage so now instead of a
thirty thousand dollar mortgage I'm
looking at a sixty thousand dollar
mortgage
now of course my kids would still pay me
for the cars and stuff like that but I'm
thinking now I'm playing I said to the
gentleman I said now I'm paying closing
costs as well is this really the
smartest thing for me to do of course
he's still on the mortgage so of course
he says yes
but none of this sounds like the
smartest thing to do if we're gonna make
a list yeah what are your other options
here
well she could stay in the loan she's in
well yeah I could stay in my eight
percent and then it's a variable so that
means I'd be attacking that thing with a
Vengeance versus rolling more and more
debt into this with a refinance and try
to get out of that co-signed loan with
your kids as quickly as possible
into their own names
I don't know
um I guess I could have them look into
it at this point yeah I'm gonna do some
more homework Angela to see how we can
get your names off of all of this debt
and stop going further into debt and
start to dig ourselves out of this if
that means extra income cutting expenses
doing whatever you have to do to get
this HELOC out of your life I'm sorry
for what you went through that's a
really tough situation not something you
ever would have chosen but we are
rooting for you to get this debt gone
ASAP more of the Ramsay show coming up
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campbell joined by Jade warshaw
this hour
if you're a pastor listening today we
know you've had a hard few years long
hours lower Church attendance all while
she trying to keep your own house
running and you've had to take care of
so much and so here at Ramsey Solutions
we want to help take care of you because
you deserve a safe space to talk about
the harder things you're dealing with
especially if you're struggling with
money and that's why we created a free
pastors only version of Financial Peace
University over six weeks you're going
to be with pastors learning with them
from all over the country how to pay off
debt and build wealth so that you can
retire with confidence
and what's really cool is that this
class is led by folks on our team who
understand the pressures that pastors
are under and they've got a heart for
you so if you want to join this free
pastors only Financial Peace University
go to ramsaysolutions.com Pastor that's
ramseysolutions.com
pastor and if you uh know a pastor in
your life in your community please let
them know about this we'd love to have
as many people impacted by this as
possible open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Rogers
up in Denver Colorado Roger welcome to
the show
thank you Jade thank you George for
taking my call sure how can we help
well I want to open up an IRA in a
brokerage account if I can invest in
mutual funds
and I've heard Dave you know asked the
question do you want to pay taxes on a
thousand dollars today or a million
dollars tomorrow
you know so I wanted to find out which
one is the best one or the best tax
advantages it's a great question
it's it's like an old riddle and there's
so many factors that go into this and of
course we're big fans of the Roth option
in general because it's going you know
you're using after tax dollars it's
growing tax-free but you withdraw it
tax-free there's no required minimum
distributions but it also factors in how
old you are so what is your age
57 okay and how much do you have right
now in retirement
oh
not much thirty thousand
do you have any other assets that you
would consider part of retirement a home
no okay so you're renting right now
uh yeah okay I've been buying uh I own a
company I've been buying uh equipment by
buying a commercial trucks and and what
is your income on the road
uh right now it's about 800 000 a year
wow my goodness hey I have a question
what has kept you from investing up till
this point
okay
I didn't know if it was dead or you know
no just you know at the end of the month
you always wonder where'd my money go I
don't have a big stereo system I don't
have big screen TV and all the CDs well
how long have you been making 800k
oh for
I'm going to say about four years Roger
I just I just put a big chunk of money
into equipment Roger this is a wake-up
call dude you you make too big of an
income how much debt do you have
uh I just bought a truck it's a hundred
and twenty thousand and a trailer for
36 000. all right okay so I just want to
double check because you said you own
your own business the 800k that's that's
bottom line right like that is pure
profit correct
oh that's gross profit I'm gonna say it
would probably be
around two hundred thousand okay that's
a whole different story so 200k is what
you're bringing home that's your net
that's what you're that's what you're
bringing home to buy the bacon all right
still an excellent income but you know I
think that you got to get your
priorities in line we got to stop
creating more debt we got to stop buying
new trucks you've got to save for
retirement it's it's creeping up on you
it's peeping and it's creeping and if
you don't make changes you are not going
to be ready I love that you're calling
in here asking about Investments but
there's some steps that you need to take
first in order to really set yourself up
uh to be ready to go and we got to
eliminate this debt we need to walk out
these baby steps all right I will that
debt will be gone within by the end of
this year are you are you on every
dollar are you using a budget yes okay
sweet so you've got a plan to win
yeah I've got it all planned out I've
got it down to how much money you know
could a penny would I make and how much
where everything's going good good I
know that by November of this year
everything will be completely paid off
okay so I just want to make sure right
now you're just looking towards the
future right because you know the way we
teach we're not investing until we get
the debt paid off and the reason for
that is so that you can throw as much
money as you're at your debt as possible
so you can get it knocked out so I'm
happy that you're doing research now but
I also want to reiterate it's not time
for that yet but let that I agree yeah
let that light up a fire under your butt
to keep going and get this debt paid off
with a Vengeance you gotta move
so Roger are you is it just you in this
business
yes okay an option you can look into
because here's the thing with the IRA
you are 57 so you can you are eligible
for the catch-up contributions but
that's still only going to be 7 500
bucks which isn't quite enough to retire
on now you how long do you plan on
working for
oh do you want to retire someday
yes let's start planning for it
I wanted to retire 10 years ago and so
part of that is this debt is holding you
back from retiring because it's holding
you back from investing and stop
stocking away a whole bunch of money and
so my A1 is to get rid of this debt and
I'm questioning if you need this truck
is there another option because I'm
guessing this truck is for your business
right
well yeah it's a semi it's a a whole
refrigerated Goods is there another
option that you where you could sell
this truck and get a cheaper used one
uh no not at this
not at this time okay this is this is a
used one okay what I'm getting so the
ra1 is to use that 200 Grand income to
pay off this 156 Grand of debt which I
think you could do in under two years
that sound reasonable
uh by November of this year wow how are
you going to do that
I have no other day I mean it's just the
truck the car the cost of food okay so
you're gonna live on nothing is what
you're saying
right I love it I spend
I spend a couple hundred bucks on food
are you a renter or do you have a
mortgage
no neither I don't maintain a house or
go wherever the truck is that that's
home
the truck I just bought is going to be
I'm putting a driver in it
okay so here's another thing to think
about Roger I want you working with an
investing professional who can help
guide this whole process over the next
several years to show you a plan and say
hey here's when you're going to be able
to retire based on the numbers we're
laying out and they're going to also
show you options where you can invest as
a person who's self-employed into
something like a solo 401K so that way
you have way more options than just that
Ira limited to 7 500 bucks that's right
and a good thing about that solo 401K
George is that you can do contributions
on each side as the employer and then
also as the employee so that's helpful
when tax day comes yeah to catch up
because you're you're obviously behind
on the retirement side but you have a
great income and I just don't want you
having to work for another 10 years if
you're even able to versus saying hey if
I can get this income up to 250 300 and
I'm throwing you know 100 200 Grand away
even if it's outside of retirement and a
brokerage account in a savings account
you'll be able to have a a retirement
with dignity at that point which is my
goal for you yep
how's that sound and now did you say it
was the Roth that it has the best so
Roth is going to go in out with after
tax dollars grow tax-free and you're
with your age it may be more beneficial
to do the traditional IRA and so that's
another thing to bring up with your
smartvester pro you can reach out to
them at ramseysolutions.com we've got
them in your area in Denver you can
click on Ramsay recommends and get in
touch with one of them to walk through
all of those options
and uh Roger one more question for you
the way your business is set up does it
require you working to bring in money or
is it something that you'll be able to
manage as you get older and have others
does that make sense delegate
yeah it'll be something that I can
manage because the the new truck I just
bought I put a driver in it it comes on
what uh it's leased on with the company
good basically they they keep that truck
moving I can go sit on the beach and
good good 10 trucks yeah I just wanted
to make sure that you had it I wanted to
make sure you had it set up in such a
way that you're not having to do the
brunt the hard labor as you get on up
there in age and that you can still
bring in some money and be sure you get
rid of this debt and then run that
business debt free Roger that is the
best path to a earlier retirement for
you we're wishing you the best man this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show I'm George
Campbell joined by Jade warshaw this
hour open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five well Jade we
saw this headline earlier this week from
Yahoo and uh I'm curious to get your
thoughts on it here it is half of Jen's
ears said they don't see a point in
saving money until things return to
normal instead they're investing in
themselves George that looks like you
know I have thoughts on this that's why
I brought it to you Jade so many
thoughts so many questions so little
time number one the what the whole part
about until things return to normal we
talked about this a little before the
segment and I'm like are they talking
about the pandemic because the pandemic
is over
we need to Define normal
what is normal well normal is broke we
know that that's free okay but they're
wanting it like normal to them I think
is everything's great the economy is
perfect I have a perfect job in the
perfect place and I can afford
everything I don't think that exists it
that is utopian it 100 does not exist
and let's look at it from this angle I
mean if you don't view times as normal
if you're still viewing times as you
know kind of like state of emergency or
like crazy inflation whatever that's the
best time to save right like that's when
we should be saving our money that's
when we should be pulling back a little
bit that's not really the time I don't
know I feel like the the thought here is
a little bit backwards for me but you
know maybe I'm not a gen zero so let's
say I'm missing something 56 of them put
their retirement planning on hold during
the pandemic which if you're in a time
where you're fearful I feel like saving
more money would be beneficial that's
what I'm saying you should be saving and
and more questions again more questions
Jen's ears so this is Young America I'm
thinking and here's my thoughts here
because I want people to retire and I
want them to invest in their retirement
early because we know that when it comes
to investing time is your friend right
but it's also making me wonder like what
you're investing already do you have
debt are you working the baby steps like
there's a way to do this and do it right
you know and they talk about here
they're prioritizing making up for those
missed years during the pandemic with
exciting experiences and good memories
George why are you promoting me George
I'm poking the bear here investing in
myself so what like starting my own
business again the the mentality here is
not making sense because on the one hand
we're like oh it's crazy times you know
we wanna we don't want to save our money
like we want to wait till it goes back
to normal but on the other hand we're
talking about business ventures I don't
know there's just a side of this that's
not making a whole lot of sense it feels
like it's a good way to justify doing
whatever I want to do because saving is
like eating your vegetables facts and so
like hey it's not the time to eat our
vegetables people okay we're in a time
of Crisis yeah the Brussels sprouts can
wait yeah they're they're this is like
me time for these people but these
quotes are just their bed I love that
they're betting on themselves or
investing in our cell is very Eat Pray
Love Like I'm gonna go find myself in
Europe and while I'm a big fan of
investing in yourself so that you can
have a better career if that means
furthering your education things like
that that's great yeah but we don't do
that at the expense of our financial
future definitely not and I mean I think
you can really have this pie in the sky
when it comes to like betting on
yourself in business but I read a stat
that said 18 of startups fail in the
first year and 50 of startups feel in
five years so that's that's risky like
if we're saying I'm gonna take my
retirement money and bet on myself now
don't get me wrong I'm all about like
chasing a dream and like going after
stuff but we've we not at the expense of
like reality like we've got to think
this thing through there's a right way
to do this we want to set ourselves up
for Success right like let's pay off our
debt let's get some great Savings in
place you know let's start saving up to
to bet on yourself but let's pay cash
for it like let's not go out and get
like business loans and no you know what
I'm saying there's a way to do this the
financial planner quoted in this said
talking about their clients said right
now they may be thinking I don't want to
put money into a retirement account
because that's taking away from the
dollars that I've been able to invest in
myself and what I'm trying to do to
achieve my dreams and create an impact
for the world LOL what in the We Are The
World Is this man mentality I don't know
George I I'm confused by it because
there was another part that said it said
um they are seeking some sort of control
because the Consumer Price Index it's
distressing stubborn inflation the stock
market volatility it says Americans are
facing Financial strain due to Rising
housing grocery costs it's also
difficult to put Faith in the stock
market which has seen significant ups
and downs they're literally burying
their head into sand and going I'm just
going to go to the beach because life is
expensive well they're like the stock
market is going up and down I don't I
don't know what to do that is really the
heart of this is there is a microwave
mindset in our culture today we're not
thinking long term we see the stock
market go down and so they go well why
would I invest in that I'm just losing
money and the thing they need to
remember is and for you guys watching
the stock market does this but it does
this as it goes up so it goes up and
down while continuously traveling up so
we know that you know if you look at the
past okay we can look at the past 30
years and then S P 500 it's still having
an annualized rate of return 10.7
percent and we're going to look it up
this time in history 10 years from now
we're gonna go oh look at that little
dip you got to zoom out zoom out be a
crock pot in a world for full of
microwaves yeah invest into your future
regardless of what's happening in the
economy yes and you'll be far better off
but do it in the right way Jen's ears
let's get our debt paid off because I
know y'all got student loan debt oh yeah
they're trying to do 17 things at once
yeah you got to focus all right good
stuff there Eric joins us up next in
Minneapolis Eric welcome to the show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help
um so I'm 19 and I just got my real
estate license early September cool and
I made some stupid decisions and I
invested a bunch of money about a year
and a half ago
and it was around 18
000 and now it's down to about 13 14
000 so pretty much over four thousand
dollars
um but I have no income and I have about
nine thousand dollars worth of debt and
normally I would just ride the roller
coaster but
um
well we just had a great conversation
about this Eric I hope you were
listening we did what did you invest in
was it single stocks
yeah it was I mean it was index funds
and single stocks
and now
uh yeah like I said normally I I take
that back and this was like your entire
world this month I bet and this was your
life savings
yeah pretty much I I just have to ask
and I'm not doing this to poke fun I I
just want to know did you get this
advice from the Graham did you get it
from Tick Tock did somebody tell you hey
dude this is what you need to take all
your money and put it here I'm just
curious because I know there's a lot of
that out there right now
no I don't I guess I don't really
remember where I I didn't even have
social media at the time but uh but
where does where did the idea come from
to go hey I've got 9 000 in debt I've
got 18 in the bank uh I'm gonna just let
the debt sit I'm gonna invest this all
that's what I want to know well so I
actually yeah so the debt came I didn't
really find the show till probably three
or four months ago the debt came after
all the Investments I actually invest I
got student loans out in order to invest
it and then I thought Michelle and then
I realized I screwed up all right this
is you just got your real estate license
I think you need to get any job right
now because it could be six months to a
year before you actually see Commission
on your first sale right that's right
right and so we need income today and so
I'm gonna go find the best job that I
can with the skills that I have that
pays the most money so that I can create
a financial Foundation uh and as far as
the stocks go you might just need to
cash out because you need money right
now and so this five thousand that you
lost I'm calling it a stupid tax and I'm
gonna learn to never do that again and
only invest into my retirement and have
a long-term mindset so that my butt
doesn't get taken from me when I lose
five thousand and you can take that
money and pay off his debt yeah because
it's going to be 13k that you're going
to receive right Eric
yeah but the and the other thing is I'm
living at home still so I it will last
me a long time so I feel like part of me
feels like if I just hang on to it and
be very well we're gonna work the baby
steps you're gonna work the baby steps
you're gonna cash out this stock you're
going to take 9k of the 13k you're gonna
pay off your debt and then you're gonna
put the next bit of money well you're
going to keep a thousand as an emergency
fund then you're gonna pay off your debt
and then in the same day you're going to
start putting towards three months of
expenses and we're gonna just walk up
the line and work these baby steps and
get a real job until Real Estate is
making you money that you can let go of
that job and do real estate full-time
and man once you you touch that hot
stove once it never happens again so I'm
glad you learned it early man we've
we've all done stupid with zeros on the
end and uh you'll look back at this and
laugh one day when you're a millionaire
and you follow these baby steps that's
right this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
folks welcome back to the Ramsay show
I'm George Campbell co-host of this show
of course as well as smart money happy
hour with our good friend Rachel Cruz
Join This Hour by Jade warshaw we're
taking your calls at triple eight eight
two five five two two five now if you're
listening to the show I imagine you
enjoy it hopefully it's helpful for you
it motivates you on your financial
journey and here's my one ask because it
is a free show would you consider
subscribing leaving a review and sharing
it with a friend we want to make big
impacts in 2023 with this message and
help people become debt free and build
wealth and that is the best way to do it
is by Word of Mouth leaving reviews
subscribing make the algorithms love it
all of that good stuff so we appreciate
you guys doing that
let's get to the phones Alex joins us in
Des Moines Alex welcome to the Ramsay
show
hello what's going on
thank you so much for taking my call
funny George that you mentioned the
making a big impact in 2023
why is that
um
excuse me
what you got going on now 22 for me and
my wife was a year of stork mode and
stupid text
um I'm currently looking at the
beginning of this year with 31k in
student loans and about
800 in medical
and a condo that we currently live in
with about 20 to 25k in equity depending
on how good a sale we get
my question is should I sell the condo
to blow off baby stuff too what's your
take-home pay
take home pay for our household is
fluctuates a little bit based on the
year but we're looking at about 50
three fifty three thousand or a hundred
yeah
fifty three thousand fifty three
thousand for the year
okay
and when it comes to this condo where
what would you guys do if you sold it
would you just rent for a while
we were doing to renting I just recently
well may
I took a job as a pastor in a smaller
town that's about a 45 minute commute
currently we would rent somewhere there
what's your mortgage payment right now
on mortgage payments
accounting the hoac is a is 7.95 a month
okay that's good that's reasonable at
least and Rural Iowa for the win I mean
looking at these numbers nothing to me
says fire mode sell the condo it feels
like a lot right now because you're
staring down 32 000 and you're bringing
home 53 but these numbers are really
encouraging to me if you guys get
intense about it
okay how much could you throw at the
debt each month if you went scorched
Earth We're on a budget written plan
we're not eating out shaving all the
subscriptions expenses working extra how
much could you throw at the debt each
month
honestly I don't know like I said when
the baby was born we went into stupid
text so I my wife and I need to really
what does that mean stupid tax to you
did you guys just haul off and buy a
bunch of stuff that you didn't need for
the baby
like so do you go into debt not quite
because I see the medical debt in
student loans
our stupid tax was more we paid off our
last credit card before we got the final
bill for the baby that's why we have
medical debt right now okay
and then we
our fast food budget quadrupled from
where it was in July I get it you got a
newborn at home nobody feels like
cooking it's like you're exhausted at
the end of the day let's just order take
out look I get it definitely been there
I I'm with George I mean I think you
guys need to sit down and crunch some
numbers it sounds like you've kind of
been you know in la la land a little bit
enjoying a new baby getting your life
together because your life is totally
different now you've just had a major
life change and you know that's cool
give yourself a little bit of Grace
there but now you see what's going on
it's time to get yeah you're ready to
make something get on the ball how much
money do you guys have in the bank
we have our 1000 emergency fund and then
at the moment we're at about 3 400 just
checking that's going in and out for
bills okay so your next day one sounds
like that medical debt which you can
knock out within the next paycheck
if we give it scorched or if that plus
my a decent working method Nation
probably be in the next paycheck Alex oh
so I should be bringing home about 4 400
a month right somewhere around there eat
yep my wife also has a seasonal job
discount in there so our January through
April is significantly higher than our
rest of the year are you doing a budget
yeah we run through every dollar every
month okay so I I want you to really
look at that and I want to right now I
feel like we have kind of like fake
numbers they're kind of like in the
clouds squishy it's very squishy I think
that we can I want you and your wife to
look at this tonight I want you to get
on every dollar and I want you to have
solid numbers in your brain going
forward this is the amount that we have
extra uh that we can put towards our
debt for this month you know and then
you know the months that come you'll
you'll cross that mountain when you get
to it but it just sounds like
everything's kind of just a guess right
now and it doesn't have to be like that
I think when things are very fluid and
it's not a real number then there's a
lot of room for anxiety and fear whereas
and it's like I don't know if we can do
this maybe we can if we buckle down but
if you really just get those numbers
then you'll know what you can do and
every dollar is great it'll help project
like exact dates for you like payoff
dates there's a debt snowball calculator
in there and here's what happens you
start to enter the numbers and you go we
got 500 extra bucks yeah and it's going
to take us 40 years to pay off this debt
that sucks we can do better than that
yeah what if we could double that okay
you get the side job we cut this number
we're going to shop our insurance we're
going to change it withholdings we're
pausing all investing wow now it's going
to take us 18 months and you start to
feel that hope and that progress and
then you go if I just live out that plan
we put on paper we're gonna be there 18
months from now no debt that's right you
need to use the tools that we have for
you and let those tools motivate you
plug in the numbers get excited bring
your wife on board you guys can do this
how's that sound Alex thank you
did you leave any more hopeful than you
came
a little bit I guess I might have just
been impatient too well that that's part
of it when you start on the Ramsay plan
there's a lot of impatience yeah because
you're like oh I can be debt free oh
yeah I want that like now yeah how do we
how do we speed up that process and
that's a great feeling to have and you
got to use that fuel and turn that into
actionable steps and habits that create
momentum and it's addictive and Jade you
experience this when you and your
husband were paying off your massive
mountain of debt you go how much more
could we do next month oh yeah and next
month well that's the thing you know I
can tell he's excited because he's like
willing if you're willing to sell your
house you're excited yeah that's next
level so it's just like what you said
George finding a way to focus that in in
just the it's like a laser right you
don't want to go crazy it's like just
focus that in just the right direction
really get intense because you know they
don't have to sell the house I mean if
they hated the house or they just want
to rent you know like sure that's an
option but you know I don't think they
need to do that I think just getting on
using those tools getting excited I did
you know I know the feeling you want to
get out of debt tomorrow but sometimes
you just have to walk out the process
and here's the thing there is something
to be said for that process it's a
wonderful thing if you have you know a
large asset that you can sell off and
become debt free I'm not mad at that I'm
not knocking anybody who does that but I
will say there's something that happens
in the process of debt snowballing that
you can't I mean it's it's invaluable it
does something in your character it does
something in your habits it does
something in your faith it does
something in your relationships and you
cannot duplicate that in any other
process so I tell people all the time
man don't try to skirt the process you
know if you don't have to go ahead and
walk through it you know it's worth it
it is worth it that sacrifice is worth
it for what's on the other side yeah
selling selling the condo while an
intense step doesn't necessarily change
the habits that got us into the Consumer
Debt in the first place and so I love
the idea of going what am I willing to
sacrifice and you realize oh I didn't
end up really needing that I didn't
really miss it I didn't miss that old
life except for maybe the eating out
that's something I can we can all say
I'm excited to get back to that once I'm
debt free oh man I know that's right and
you know I have to say this because
somebody asked me about debt
consolidation the other day and I was
like that's the other thing with debt
consolidation you put it all together I
feel like you did something you feel
like you did something you think oh I
have one payment I have less debt and
you're more likely to take on more debt
and you don't do the debt snowball
position when I clean my house and it
all goes in the junk drawer and
everything looks clean I go I did it
it's a trap nope the junk is just not to
be seen right now it's still there there
is purpose in the process people love it
good hour thank you so much to my
co-host Jade warshaw to all the folks in
Booth we got Austin Ben James Zack and
Andrew and you America thank you so much
for listening we'll be back real soon on
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do you love a good day Brandt want to
see the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsey personality George
Campbell joined by our newest
personality Jade warshaw and we are so
excited to take your calls today at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five if you need a second opinion a
third opinion some advice some
confidence and a decision we want to
help you take that right Next Step for
your money triple eight eight two five
five two two five Cliff kicks off this
hour in Knoxville Tennessee Cliff
welcome to the show
Cliff are you there oh can you hear me
yes you sound great
okay good uh thanks for taking my call
what's going on
so I I'm new to this investing thing my
wife put me on to your show I've been
listening for a little while
um so I had no debt my house is paid for
my vehicles paid for
I just built up forty thousand dollars
in my emergency fund
and so last year I put about 15 000 into
the S P 500 and kind of that was right
before the Ukraine war started before
the crash
yeah so that's worth about 13 000 right
now
um and I had a little
um I was in the Army when I was a kid
when I got out uh I put 3000 into a Roth
IRA when I was like 20.
um so I've had that forever and just
yesterday from listening to y'all and
thinking about it I put 40 000 into two
mutual funds and then I bought I did the
IR Ira for last year and for this year
so all my my question that left me with
ninety thousand dollars left over you
just got cash sitting everywhere man way
to go cliff That Ain't a Bad Thing how
old are you yeah I know
I'll be 38 here in March well first of
all great job I thought you're gonna be
like I'm 70. and I mean you're doing so
great at 38 years old my guy is killing
it this man has no debt he's got all
this money saved he funded last year's
Roth this year's Roth you're like the
poster child and my screen says you have
90k in savings
yeah that's that's what's left over it's
it's just sitting in a savings account
you know making very little and that's
beyond your uh emergency funds you got
40 in the emergency fund 90 in savings
mm-hmm
yeah I've got 40 and and when I want an
account that's my like just my sort of
walking around money in case something
bad happens
um and I had a hundred and thirty as my
in just sitting in savings I wanted to
buy land I'm real land hungry I own
three acres right now and I want more
and the house I live in like I said it's
paid for but it's just it's a little
Shack like I'm shivering right now
because it's cold
um you need to upgrade but yeah yeah I
need to do something what's your income
I had a hunt
so that's the thing too I'm an
archaeologist by trade but that is real
spotty work
um I'm also a musician believe it or not
I make most of my money
as a musician and then I also I work
doing construction and odd jobs and
stuff like that I'm just I need to pile
up money what a Renaissance area you're
different man you're different I like it
so I'm glad to hear that the way I like
to think about what to do with money is
obviously our seven baby steps which
you've kind of walked through
accidentally it sounds like living debt
free paying off the house investing for
the future but beyond that I want you to
think about what is where does Cliff
want to be at 40 at 45 at 50 where does
he want to be living and so part of that
is we got to get you upgraded in-house
and you've been living dead free I think
it'd be really cool to be able to pay
cash for something absolutely uh and
beyond that obviously investing in
retirement accounts that are tax
advantaged it sounds like you've been
throwing money into brokerage accounts
outside of retirement because you don't
have a lot of options are you kind of
self-employed
yeah yeah I am basically my steady
income that's the most is is
self-employed as a musician and a music
teacher believe it or not that's where I
like in the past couple years I made a
hundred almost about a hundred thousand
a year mostly with the music which is
kind of crazy awesome so the way I'm
thinking about this for all intents and
purposes Cliff is in baby step seven
however you know the way I think about
it with money you can do three things
with it you can give it you can save it
you can spend it right so you've done a
decently good job at saving it you know
you've gotten your debt paid off you've
got your emergency funds you've even
gotten into your retirement
um you've got things saved you can spend
some of it and if I'm I agree with
George I think that you can start
looking into you know a nice place you
know what I'm saying something that's
within your means we're not going to go
overboard but something that fits right
with your income of 100K you know it
looks like you might you know have a
head start possibly on it on a down
payment and then I also want you to
start thinking about some generosity are
you have you had some opportunity to
give uh recently
no no I've never like donated money I do
free music lessons for youngsters okay
that's kind of that's great
from those three three angles and if I
agree with George I think Now's the Time
to start looking at a place something
that you can afford possibly pay cash
for are you wanting to like build on
land or are you going to just buy a
property somewhere
I wanted to just invest in undeveloped
land but you know I searched around I
had 130 I could not find anything that I
liked and for 130 I mean it just wasn't
enough so that's when I just yesterday I
put the 40 into two mutual funds left me
over with 90 and the thing is this place
where I currently live is just a little
Shack and the shack needs a lot of work
it's real uncomfortable but it's on
three really nice Acres I only paid 50
000 cash for this whole place
yeah I don't know I need to figure that
out it's a 1920 it's a historic home
um but so you just build a home on the
property
I've thought about that too it's kind of
with the way that the where the well is
the other build site it would impede if
I put septic up there it would impede on
the well boundary so I kind of can't
really build another structure I think
what I'd love to do is restore this home
to its former glory of the sharecropper
house make it make it a nice little
place would 90 000 do that for you
yeah that's just I think 90 would do it
I'm just so that's what my question was
my wife wants me to renovate so she's
already she makes her own money and
she's bought herself a nice other place
where she's you know we we kind of split
time between the two places she wants me
to renovate this place and make it real
nice
I'm hoping that so where's your other
place is that just a normal house in a
neighborhood
she bought us this 1930s brick Farmhouse
that's uh it's it's nice she did she she
dumped a bunch of money into that and
made it pretty nice
um can that can that be your primary
residence I'm a little bit confused
are you guys doing these things together
no they're not yeah
your incomes yeah he said she bought the
house
yeah we're on two separate pages and she
works out of town most of the time and
I'm here at my place Cliff you just
threw a wrench in our plans man bigger
conversation I think we got to get on
the same page before we make any another
big financial decision yeah cause y'all
got a house you got multiple houses but
it sounds like y'all are uh just
roommates when you want to be so I'd
work on that part first but you've got
the ability to renovate this or put a
down payment on a home you got this man
thanks for the call this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show I'm George
Campbell joined by Jade warshaw this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the number to call you
jump in we'll talk about your life and
your money well Jade I wanted to talk
about something that is about as
exciting as stepping on a Lego brick and
that is taxes but I want to make sure
our audience knows about all the tax
changes maybe some tips and tricks to
help them along the way remind them of
some deadlines yeah all the good stuff
let's do it so let's start with the the
big day to celebrate the holidays aren't
over April 18th is the filing deadline
for all federal tax returns and payments
you can start filing at the end of this
month you'll start getting those W-2s
from your employer if that's your
situation don't put it off guys no and
the good news is you can start getting
some of the paperwork ready now which is
you know make it a date night have fun
with it you're going to start getting
those paperworks in for your investment
statements mortgage interest statements
1099s or whatever have you just kind of
pull all those together put them in a
folder for when it's time that's right
and the extension deadline is October
16th if you are in that bucket there and
so there's some good news about this
year's taxes there are some some bad
news too you yeah so the good the good
news is uh the standard deduction
continues to climb which is good because
that lowers your taxable income yes that
is correct we like that anything that's
going to make us pay less taxes that is
a good thing you want the bad news now I
no you know what George Let's skip that
I'm just kidding we can't skip it well
the bad news is uh you're gonna get a
smaller refund this year across the
board because there was no economic
impact so you remember all the expanded
tax credits like it was like and you
have a kids here's five thousand dollars
and you have a kid bro they went off
like the amount of money that was coming
through I was like what we have two kids
I was like what is happening this is
different it was wild time so all of
that is gone the expanded tax credits
and deductions are reverting back to
their pre-covered 19 amounts the
charitable charitable contributions
deduction that is out and so uh if most
people are gonna file with the standard
deduction yes so only do itemized if you
can get more than you would have with
the standard yeah and you need to really
sit down with a professional to really
see how that works especially get a
business a small business you definitely
want to get into that with a you know
because you got the personal side in
your business side so yes so if you're
wondering all right I may not get a
refund I might owe how do I save some
money this tax season well the two magic
words are deductions and credits hit me
and these two can get Squishy in
people's brains so here's an easy way to
think about it deductions help lower the
amount of your income that can be taxed
so that's kind of before that's right
after the tax credits so think about you
get your final bill at the restaurant
this is going to it's like actually give
you credits off of that final bill
amount and so think about things like
Earned Income Tax Credit child tax
credit you've heard that Child
Independent Care Credit education credit
so you need to be aware of all the
credits and deductions you might qualify
for yep yep and again working with a tax
professional they'll help you know that
I mean you don't have to know everything
but it's good to go in there with an
idea to just kind of make sure
everything's on the up and up you know
what I'm saying yes and to add to your
homework here there are something called
above the line deductions which are
really helpful so there's things you can
still do even though we're in 2023 to
lower your taxable great idea yeah talk
about that that's great so one of them
that is great is the HSA if you have a
high deductible health plan with an HSA
and you contributed to that HSA you can
deduct that for your taxable income so
it's not too late to do that it's not
another one is IRAs if you fund your
traditional IRA you can do that through
you know April 18th and I think a lot of
people forget that I think people think
that it's over in January because like
the year is restarting but you've got
until you've got until tax day April
18th yeah funding and I like to I'm a
nerd I like to get my taxes done as
early as possible but here's why I want
to know if I'm going to owe if I'm gonna
have a refund because you don't owe that
money until April 18th that's true well
let's talk about that a little bit
because I know a lot of people are like
oh I'm gonna get my tax refund I'm gonna
do my taxes I want to do my taxes early
so I can get my thousands and thousands
of dollar check so I can I don't know go
do something that you're probably gonna
spend it all it's like they think Uncle
Sam is Uncle Santa and he's just gifting
you money because you've been such a
good boy it's a horrible it's just
horrible the amount of money that people
lend the government with no interest
zero percent man I wish man that drives
me crazy so here's the deal if you get a
refund it it is not a blessing yes it's
better than like owing ten thousand
dollars but you are just lending that
money to the government interest free
when you do that so you want to get as
close to zero as possible believe it or
not you don't you don't want to owe much
and you don't want to get a big refund
and there's something mentally about
that right when you when you set up your
withholdings to where it's correct right
you're not yeah you get the perfect
amount you get the perfect amount but
then that money is is cash flow within
your normal monthly you know flow and
you're more likely to do something smart
with that money it's going to be worked
into your budget when you've got a
refund towards death let's go into
something fun I know y'all
you're getting you're getting jet skis
you're out here buying I don't know a
Peloton y'all are out here really buying
things with these with these returns
you're going on vacation unless you're a
Disney if you're a baby stepper you're
like sweet that's going towards my dad
that's true that is true I just think
it's harder that way it is I think it's
like we're all children deep down I need
to know do you happen to know the
average I don't know if there's a number
for that like the average return I was
talking to a friend it's like three
grand oh that's just in my head I was
talking to a friend he was I said what
like what type of return like what type
of tax return do you get he said his was
eight thousand dollars
wow eight that is that normal somebody
needs to come into my DMs at Jade
warshaw and tell me is that normal I
can't be right so here's here's the
thing to think about if you're trying to
pay off debt and you're like well
inflation and there's so much happening
in the economy I don't have the margin
to pay off debt one thing you can do is
change those withholdings that you keep
getting a big refund every year because
that money will go back into your bank
account instead of sitting with Uncle
Sam all year and that's what we're
talking about we're talking about you uh
being able to get the maximum amount out
of your paycheck you know sometimes the
way it's set up automatically it's not
in your best interest and you can
actually go back on there claim more
dependents however it is that you do it
to even that out so you're having more
money in your check each month and like
I said before chances are you're going
to be smarter at spending that money yes
and our team has painstakingly created
an amazing Hub as a resource to all of
our listeners out there at
ramseysolutions.com
taxes so we have articles resources
there's an incredible tax prep checklist
that's free I use it every year and I
just go down the line and I start going
yup got that up I gotta go print that I
gotta go save that good job George I'm I
know I told you I'm a nerd I am when you
said that you did it I really imagined
it and I was like yes George does do
this I live it out I can see it and the
the other thing you can do is if you are
one of those that does it on your own
you use software you've got to check out
Ramsay smart tax this is the no-nonsense
tax software that you can actually trust
there's no hidden fees there's no hidden
agenda we're not here as a gateway drug
to get you into debt products like
TurboTax uh sorry I said it out loud hey
George you know what I told you know
what I told you before the break yes you
have a experience with Intuit which is
the parent company guys I
I it's hard for me to even get it out of
my mouth if you're wondering I used to
refer into it if you're wondering why I
have feelings about that we did an
entire episode on my podcast to find
print about Turbo Tax and how Turbo Tax
is trying to screw you over I remember
their shareholder uh presentation about
how they're going to make a bajillion
dollars from you all America and it has
nothing to do with taxes it's about how
they're going to use you to create loans
and debt and create money from interest
to make themselves bajillionaires yeah
when you stay broke it's not good no I
did into it as a side Hustle
I'm glad you kept it on the side and now
it's it's gone it's gone oh she gone
whoa well you can check out check out
all those resources including Ramsay
smart tax our awesome tax software just
go to
ramsaysolutions.com taxes and like I
said I know this is no one's favorite
thing to think about it's not on your
top 10 list of favorite things it's
number 11 for me I was gonna say I think
you like this George I think this is
this might be I like you know what it
feels very productive to get it done and
here's what me and my wife do we will
schedule a a date
right after we finish our taxes we go to
a really nice meal
to treat ourselves because we're
adulting I'm so proud of you let me tell
you something if Sam warshaw said to me
jade the date night is tax night post
tax returns shutting her down I'm
shutting it down right there I'm like
what okay not quite romantic I need to
do a better job of that no George you do
your Thug but it just it's good to get
it in the rear view mirror get it done
folks if you do tax software go ahead
and start that process the end of
January meet with a tax Pro that's great
schedule that now because it's about to
get crazy for those tax preparers out
there and don't go to those h r blocks
Mart find a real professional start a
dog H R Block but be real
so ramseysolutions.com taxes is the
place to go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show I'm George camel
joined by Jade warshaw this hour the
number to call is triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money
Caleb joins us up next in Springfield
Missouri Caleb welcome to the show
hi George and Jay thanks for taking my
call how are you two this afternoon
we're doing lovely how can we help today
good um so they told me to get the blunt
with the question up front and then fill
in the details later so uh my question
is
um how long would I have to plan to live
in a house for it to be worth the hassle
and the cost of buying
um and then later reselling it sounds
like you already have an exit strategy
tell us about that
um well I don't really I don't have an
exit strategy or anything like that I'm
currently living in an apartment
um and uh I'm just I'm sort of planning
for a head after the uh after my leases
expire
um and thinking about like if I need to
purchase a house right then or um if I
need to wait a little longer so I'm
trying to figure out like for how long
do I think I will be living in a given
house for it to be worth the hassle of
purchasing it okay well I'll hit you
with just some general details then
we'll dive into your number specifically
and talk about it so in general you want
to at least recoup the cost of
purchasing the home so all the closing
costs that are involved there's also
going to be potential capital gains so
if you sell that home you haven't lived
there for two years and you go and sell
it and you make a hundred thousand
dollars profit from when you bought it
to when you sold it that will count as
taxable income and so you want to be
careful about things like that because
if you stay there for two years you get
to keep up to 250 000 if it's just you
and if you're married you can keep up to
500 000 in profit before ever paying a
dime in taxes
so that's one thing to think about if
you're going to be there for a short
amount of time so what's your financial
situation right now are you do you have
any debt what's your income how much do
you have saved
sure yeah so I just left graduate school
and started a new job a couple weeks ago
um it's 78 000 gross and about 58 000
take home after like taxes and insurance
and benefits and whatnot okay
and do you have any debt
I have 10 000 in student loans and I'm
currently I'm following your baby steps
the best I can I'm on step one um and I
laid out a plan that should get me
through one two and three by the end of
this year so I think I've got the the
debt should be okay after that awesome
so 2024 you're completely debt free
you're at baby step four you're
investing fifteen percent of your
household income and you got to start
saving the down payment at that point
okay okay so have you looked at the area
you want to buy a home in and to see
what it's going to cost
uh not too much in depth now okay well a
good parameter to get you started here
if you take your take-home pay now you
can deduct the kind of all the every
anything beyond your normal taxes like
your your health care your 401k if you
took those out of the equation I want
your payment to be no more than a
quarter of your take-home pay on a
15-year fixed rate mortgage
okay and obviously the 15-year mortgage
is going to have a higher payment than
the 30-year mortgage so that's something
to take into account but the goal here
is to be in debt as little as possible
for a short amount of time as possible
so that you're debt free living like no
one else down the line
and that helps dictate your down payment
on how much you need to save okay
okay how much would I so if it's if it's
a quarter of my after-tax income uh on
the 15-year fixed rate mortgage um just
for regular payments how much do you
recommend saving up for the down payment
uh you know if you can get 20 down
that's amazing because on a conventional
mortgage you're gonna you know get rid
of PMI at that point private mortgage
insurance but you know for a first-time
home purchase you know you might not be
able to get up to 20 so get as much as
you can for sure for sure minimum 10. we
want you to you know you want to have
skin in the game we don't want you to
purchase a house and be have the
potential at all to ever be upside down
so making sure that you're putting down
a decent down payment it kind of guards
against that
right okay gotcha and then the uh back
to the the how long I'd be living in it
for the the minimum for getting rid of
that capital gains income taxable income
situation that would be two years you
said two years
is that okay that's the current IRS rule
so that would be my game plan and you
know buying a house for your primary
residence it should be kind of a
long-term thing you don't want to be
jumping in and out because when you sell
that there's going to be a lot of fees
closing costs associated with it so it's
inexpensive and you mentioned it's it's
a hassle it's a lot of work to move and
so yeah I plan on staying there for at
least two years that's your plans to
move elsewhere soon after
do what I'm sorry do you have plans to
move within a few years uh
not not to move like from the area
so uh the reason I was asking is because
I don't at the moment have any um like
romantic prospects or anything like that
but I was uh thinking once I like got
married you know we'd want to move into
a separate house together so I was I was
planning on that it would be the only
reason that I would be moving out early
yeah I mean if you're getting married I
would wait to buy I think that you guys
could rent for a year together and kind
of get an idea of what your life is
going to look like that sort of thing
because like George said it's expensive
to buy a house it's expensive to sell a
house it's expensive to move so you
really want to think through uh what
your life is going to be like before you
make such a a large purchase for sure
but there's no no one special in the
picture right now Caleb
no okay so you got time then I would
move forward with your life as is and
when you're ready to buy a house you go
ahead and do that man being a homeowner
is is special when you do it the right
way thanks so much for the call we've
also got a great mortgage calculator for
you at ramseysolutions.com under the
tool section that you can use to start
crunching those numbers all right let's
move on to Joshua and Orlando Joshua
welcome to the show
hey guys how you doing we're doing great
how can we help
so I'm currently 18 years old and I am
living in Florida at the moment
um I am a full-time student at a trade
school to become a welder I'm also
online and then I'm uh also another
full-time student for another College
online uh getting my business
administration degree both colleges are
going to be fully paid for through
scholarships and FAFSA and Pell Grant
way to go yeah
yeah thank you and um
so I'll be graduating here in mid-may
through for my uh welding school and so
I plan on doing traveling welding uh so
I'll be a little bit on the road well
and so my problem is is that I'm going
to need a truck and a camper later on
and right now
um as you can finally assume I'm in no
really financial situation to really be
paying paying cash for these things
um I have no credit cards so I have no
credit score and I'm worried about when
if I ever get a loan divide these things
uh the interest rates are just going to
kill me
um I don't really know how to really
approach these cities the Smart Way
um so I'm just kind of needing an answer
right now I'm just really lost right now
on what to do and really be having or
really to have to think about this
situation yeah I think that first things
first you've you've done a good job you
know you're going to college debt free
you know everything that I hear you
saying sounds good until the point that
you said if I ever get alone if I ever
get a loan and the question or the
response to that is you need to tell
yourself I'm not ever going to get a
loan
like you need to take debt off the table
in this in your life because the moment
that you start thinking through that
lens in my mind it eliminates a whole
bunch of other options right you need to
keep your mind open and free for lots of
ideas right so let's take debt off the
table and let's really start
brainstorming what that can look like
right George absolutely so when you when
you go all right if debt wasn't an
option what would you do Joshua you'd
get creative right you'd start looking
at used equipment you try to get deals
you negotiate it's going to take longer
so you might need to work locally and
have this be a one to two year dream
yeah it's something where maybe you can
work next to someone kind of trade and
learn it learn the business very well
while you're saving up money and you
know it's not to say that you can't weld
during that time right I don't I'll be
honest I don't know a whole lot about
the travel welding position but it's not
to say that you can't be involved in
that career field while you're saving to
do your business because at the end of
the day when you want to do a business
you got to move at the speed of cash
right the moment you start bringing debt
your risk it skyrockets
and at 18 years old well at any age you
don't need that kind of risk in your
life it changes the game when you run
this business debt free and do it from
the start that's how Dave Ramsey built
this company this building that we're
standing in paid for in cash and it's
hard to believe Joshua but I'm gonna
send you his best-selling book entree
leadership how he built this thing from
a card table in his living room to the
Empire that it is today and it took time
but he did it all with cash without
owing anyone anything and that changes
the decisions you make yes as an
entrepreneur and so I'm rooting for you
hang on the line Austin's gonna pick up
we're going to send you that book entree
leadership
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
show I'm George Campbell Ramsey
personality joined by my colleague Jade
warshaw and we are taking your calls at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five well about this time of year we get
flooded with calls on the Ramsey Show
because everyone is looking for a fresh
start with their money especially after
a cuffed up of the ears maybe maybe
there was some regrets some Financial
hangover from the holiday spending maybe
you had some stupid tax and you did some
done with zeros on the end well if
that's you you can't wish for things to
change and expect it to happen you've
got to do some different things with
your money and have a plan and we can
teach you that plan in Financial Peace
University this is the course that will
help you rethink how you manage your
money and you're going to learn step by
step how to pay off debt and how to
build wealth
and here's what's crazy nearly 10
million people have taken FPU they've
followed this plan and changed their
lives I'm one of those people this stuff
works don't try to reinvent it don't try
to do your own plan I'm telling you this
one works every time you work and when
you intentionally follow this plan with
Focus intensity this year will be
different you will have more peace in
your finances and your life you're going
to sleep better you're going to make
different decisions for your financial
future so get started today Financial
Peace University go to
ramseysolutions.com
FPU that's ramseysolutions.com
FPU I try to tell these people Financial
Peace University can change your life
George it's one of those things like you
always hear people talk about it you're
like oh yeah she's just real excited
about that no I'm not gonna do it oh I
get it I get it I'm excited because
because of what it does you know it's
it's it's it truly changes your life I
can't say it enough I mean a lot of you
listening maybe you've heard my story
maybe you haven't my husband and I paid
off 460 000 of debt because of the
teachings in FPU we were in life
thinking this is just our life sucks
like this is this is just our lot in
life until we heard about this and it
was Dave we heard Dave talking about on
the radio and then you know from there
the rest is history but I don't think
people really grasp how this can change
your life and you know not only that but
you know my husband Sam and I we've gone
on to coordinate other FPU classes and
we have seen people's payoff I mean
buddies of mine last year this time they
paid off 74k my sister paid off over
100k a buddy of mine you know they they
text me hey we just paid off our car hey
we just did this it's possible it's
possible to become free matter of fact
George I'm thinking about coordinating
an FPU class let's go if enough people
show interest I will coordinate the
class and I will make sure y'all the
virtual class are we talking one in
person man I think we should do both
because people are like I can't come to
Nashville Jade we'll we'll get a virtual
class going so you can join us wherever
you are versus something about being
around other people even if it's virtual
obviously in person is going to be the
best but something about it where you go
oh I'm not alone and I'm not crazy and
other people are sacrificing too I can
do what they if they could do it I could
do it there's an amazing things that
thing that happens there it's
accountability it's the accountability
of showing up and knowing all right you
know Biff he did his budget I gotta make
sure I do my budget if budget it Biff
did the budget you got to get your
budget done all right I love that
ramsesolutions.com FPU this is the year
you just do it instead of thinking about
doing it change your life Giovanni's up
next in Denver Giovanni welcome to the
Ramsay show
thank you how are you doing today we're
doing great how can we help
great so I just uh made a horrible
financial decision I leased a car now
I'm uh 17 000 in depth yes and um I'm a
full-time student
um thankfully I'm on Full Ride
scholarship they pay for food uh housing
and books everything nice um I work
three jobs
um I'm a videographer and editor and an
assistant producer awesome what's your
income doing all that
um well it really depends on me and how
many hours I work but usually it's just
around uh what two thousand a month okay
and that's like if you're busting it or
is that just an average if you're
doing your normal thing that's just it
if I'm just doing my normal thing okay
what's the payment on the lease
it's uh 300 and then insurance is like
around 400 yippies ouch so you're 700
bucks a month is an expense and you're
making two on a on a decent month
yeah all right do you have any other
expenses any other debt
uh no no I don't have any college debt
or I have a hundred dollars in debt of a
credit card but uh okay well A1 is just
let's pay that off let's cut up the
cards and say no more we're using
Giovanni's money and not the banks
okay so that's an easy start that's a
quick win you can do as soon as you're
off this call and I want you to remember
the pain of this moment Giovanni I want
you to remember how you feel right now
which is like dude I just screwed myself
big time because this moment right here
is what's going to make you not go back
into debt hopefully ever again right
yeah for sure all right so we're gonna
get ourselves out of this thing and
there is a way to do it depending on the
terms that you sign do you know what the
car is worth
uh yeah on Kelly Blue Book it's like
worth what eight thousand nine thousand
so it's only worth eight thousand and
you owe seventeen
uh yeah it's a 2000 so I I at least a
used car
you lease how much do you how much do
you owe like what's on the lease
oh uh so it's I bought it for 11 000 and
then there's this finance charge of five
thousand oh okay you had mentioned 17
earlier
all right
have you found out the early buyout
amount from the the lender
uh no I haven't called about that yet
okay that would be your next piece of
homework to find out is what it would
cost to buy yourself out of this lease
and then based on what the car is
actually worth that gives you a kind of
number to go all right
either I'm underwater on this thing in
which case it would be the only time we
would tell you hey go down to your local
credit union and get a small loan to
cover the difference so that you're able
to pay that car off and now at least we
have a you know a four thousand dollar
loan instead of a 11 000 loan
so how it works would I just uh sell the
car first and use that money or get the
title in my hands first you're gonna
need the title in hand
but you can't do that until you won't
have a clean title until the car is paid
off so you need to pay it off first to
have the title to then sell it
um and you're gonna need to get a
probably a small loan to do this if
you're underwater it sounds like he
might need a decent like depending on
what it's worth if it's only if it's
truly only worth eight thousand which
still feels super low it does is it
because of the used car market slowing
down
I'm not sure it's uh that's what I got
on on Kelly Blue Book that I was pretty
disappointed it's a 2011 uh
Mercedes-Benz c-cross I bought it
because I thought it would get me more
clients
um make me feel more established it was
a stupid decision I've never once worked
with a videographer because they drove a
Mercedes I work with them because their
work was excellent facts yes yes which I
know you know that now yeah but just for
anyone listening out there who's like
whoa if I get a Mercedes more people
want to work with me because I think I'm
really successful that's what they do on
real estate
well those people are divas yeah okay so
Giovanni you got your homework ahead of
you man but this is a this is one of
those stupid tax situations where you go
remember when I was a knucklehead at 18
and I made that stupid decision never
leasing a car again Gonna Save up and
pay cash for that used car and uh to get
myself out of the situation that's right
and a key point that George made is you
know after because you are gonna have to
pay some stupid tax on this I you know
hopefully it's not 8 000 hopefully it's
worth a bit more but if you end up
getting a loan to cover the difference
yeah you know a six thousand dollar loan
is better than being 17 000 in debt but
the key is the money that you gain from
the sell of the car that is your car
budget that's what you're spending on
the next car and you're paying for it
cash and then you got to pay whatever
debt off you know from from getting out
of that lease and and I gotta for
anybody listening
when it comes to car leases you know you
you hear us say all the time and Dave
used to say it's not a car lease it's a
car fleece right because it you're
getting screwed you're getting screwed
every way that uh that this thing can
get you and I think a lot of people
don't realize this because I'll be
honest you know back in the day Giovanni
I thought that car leases were for rich
people I thought that that was the way
like if you want to show your status you
get a car lease boy was I wrong I was so
wrong because they get they get you four
ways if you don't if you're out here
listening and you don't understand this
car leases get you four ways number one
you know he's got to use the lease but
most people use lease a brand new car
right and a lot of us don't realize this
but the cost of that goes down 60 to 70
percent in the first four years so they
build that in then they add in interest
which they call cost of capital and then
they add in you know their own profit
and then wear and tear you're getting
screwed people gross well Giovanni keep
working your tail off on those side gigs
to get as much income as you come sock
away that cash that you can get a beater
car once that lease is out of your hair
man sorry to hear that that puts this
hour of the Ramsay show in the books my
thanks to my co-host Jade warshaw all
the folks in the booth keeping the show
float and you America thank you for
listening we'll be back before you know
it
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsey show where America hangs out to
have a conversation about your life and
your money I'm Ramsay personality George
Campbell Join This Hour by my good
friend Jade warshaw and we are taking
your calls America at the number eight
eight two five five two two five that's
triple eight eight two five five two two
five William kicks us off in Wisconsin
William welcome to the Ramsey show how
you doing
good good how are you guys doing doing
great what's going on
so I'm 20 years old and I recently
bought my first two cars to rent out on
this app called turo how do you guys
feel about someone investing into this
business model as a way to generate more
income
yeah it depends on how you're investing
are you paying cash
so for the first two cars I have paid
cash
um and then my plan is just to save
whatever the cars make and then slowly
buy more
and my question about this is is
obviously the cars depreciate and if I
kept buying more it would probably be
over like 50 of your income
how do you guys feel about that
what so you have a primary car that
you're driving and that's not being
rented out
yeah that's separate from the other two
what was the cost of the other two cars
that you bought for this
so one of them is 11 000 and then the
other one's a little bit more expensive
I think it comes in around twenty five
thousand dollars you paid cash for these
wow at 20.
yeah I have a different business that
I've tried tried to save as much as
possible what's the other business
because it sounds like you should just
go to plan on that one
um so that's actually like uh I I've
been doing like YouTube videos for for
like four four and a half years now and
it's just like Vlogs about like
different things that I do so I've also
been filming content about the cars as
well okay good for you yeah very good
well I mean here's the way I look at it
if you could watch this money burn and
your life is gonna be okay and you just
want to do this as a fun side hustle
knowing it may not Roi quickly or at all
then and I say go for it
the way you've done it so far is not
stupid now if you were taking out loans
for these cars as they'd appreciated and
you're hoping to make back that thirty
six thousand dollar initial investment
you're not going to see that for a long
time
okay but the way you've done it have you
done this previously it sounds like you
have experience with churro
yeah so with the two cars I have it's
going well
um obviously like it's hard to hard to
know how well it's going because like
it's hard to account for like the
depreciation of the car since they're
they're probably getting like 30 000
miles per year for each car so like
they're obviously going to depreciate
pretty quickly
um I think I feel like there's formulas
and algorithms to figure that out
what that rate is going to be
I feel like you can research that and
find out I know it's out there you know
I'm not into that world heavily but I
believe that there's research where you
can find out what that value is and that
way you're you're finding out if the
prices that you're having that you're
setting are offsetting that enough to
where you're really
you know creating the profit that you
need to make money long term
so that's the equation that you're
solving for
for sure for sure and on top of like
investing in these cars would you guys
think that that should be more of a size
thing because like for for the most part
I've been saving money and then as much
as I can put into the cars I've been
I've been doing that pretty much
exclusively
it just feels like a lot of work yeah
and I don't know I mean I know they take
a huge commission making me up to 40
right
they keep so they have a few different
plans because it also comes with
insurance the plan I'm on is they
actually only take 10 so because you're
providing the insurance yeah I have to
buy like separate insurance for each car
so you got to factor that in on top of
the depreciation you're paying a whole
lot more for insurance
it's like here's what I'm getting it
sounds like you're kind of winging it
right now and it feels like you need to
settle down and really like George is
saying get all your numbers get all the
information and really put this into a
business plan to see how what what
percentage of money you're actually
making in this and how much of your time
you're putting into it yeah you could
put that same time into your YouTube
channel and you could get 5x what you're
making on turo I'm just gonna go all in
on the YouTube channel I know that's
right because that's a it's a lot of
work turo is not exactly you know
passive income I know my guy just
dropped 36 000 on on cash cars just like
lickety-split so I feel like I feel like
YouTube's been good to you dude
yeah so yeah that's definitely something
to consider because I know you guys have
also talked about like airbnbs and stuff
and it's like I look at like the cash
flow on that compared to like doing like
long-term rentals because that's also
something I've looked into and it's like
you can make so much more return on your
investment doing like the short-term
rentals well long term I would I think
real estate is a better investment
because that property is going to
appreciate it that's right and so I
think you're you're doing great for your
age I'm not worried about you you're a
great entrepreneur but I would track
every single number and at the end of
the next you know six months ago was
this worth it should I continue doing
this or is there something that's you
know worth my time yeah I worry about
that George having so much money tied up
in assets that are going down in value
that's I mean as he might we don't know
what the people are going to do to that
car obviously he's got extra insurance
but the wear and tear on that thing it
just feels like a lot of Hands-On work
yeah there's a lot of risk a lot of
unknown in that yeah you know so a more
power table I mean I I haven't done it
myself but it it's a cool business model
for sure especially with the rental car
market as it is true that all right
let's go to Benjamin in Atlanta Benjamin
what's up
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's going on yeah so um my question
is I'm on baby step six I'm a big follow
of the bay Ramsey philosophy and
yesterday I had a conversation with my
financial planner and um she insisted
that
basically you're just kind of seeing it
for me not to um to put 24 of my income
23 some some more around there hey
Benjamin could you talk directly into
your phone
we're having a hard time hearing you
yes can you hear me that's better all
right so your financial planner wants
you to invest 23 of your income
roughly yeah about there I'm getting 16
right now in my 401k and because I have
a low uh interest rate on my uh home
loan
um just pay basically the Min payments
and just build up my 401k and I was
trying to explain to her you know my
goal is like to get my house paid off
and maybe another 10 to 12 years
somewhere around there and um she
understands some value in it but she
certainly thinks the better path is to
um put the more money in the 401K
because she could generate more profit
from you know what money I put in there
that she could you know manage and I
just wanted to have some ammunition to
take back I mean overall I like the
service and I just want to know what you
guys think about it specifically well
it's like asking a dentist if you need a
cavity I mean she's benefiting from this
as well of course right if you're
putting money with her instead of your
mortgage she's benefited and you guys
have different goals and so if I'm
working with a coach and we don't align
with our goals I'm going to find a new
coach Hit the Road Jack and don't you
come yeah I'm not going to jump in
because Jade's a better singer but
that's exactly how I feel I would just
say hey it's been great working with you
I appreciate your time I gotta go work
with someone who perfectly aligns with
what I'm after she's not for your
freedom and that's why Benjamin go
connect with a smartvester pro at
ramsaysolutions.com they're going to
follow the Ramsay way which is clearly
what you're wanting to do and guess what
you're going to be a multi-millionaire
if you follow this plan yep right now
your A1 is to yes you're investing 15
but also get rid of that mortgage
payment because guess what you can do
without a mortgage payment invest way
more okay than even 23 okay I need me a
paid off house that's what I'm getting
to so uh I I'm assuming they're not a
smart investor Pro because they're not
doing things the Ramsay way so jump onto
our website get connected with one and
uh tell them to hit the road Jack or
whatever her name is that'd be cool for
this Jack probably not though Jacqueline
more of the Ramsay show coming up triple
eight eight two five five two two five
foreign
[Music]
this is the Ramsay show now most of you
you're saying good riddance to last year
because it was hard enough just to keep
gas in the tank food in the fridge and
money's still tight a few days later and
you're wondering is 2023 going to be any
different well good news you don't have
to live through another year of stress
and worry and that's why I want you to
tune in to Building Wealth in 2023 our
free live stream event on January 12th
Whoa We want to show you that you can
still make progress on your goals you
can build wealth you can have peace with
money even in this crazy economy now
during this event you're going to hear
from Dave Ramsey Rachel Cruz myself Dr
John deloney and Ken Coleman we're going
to talk about how to set goals and how
to create margin so that you can build
wealth this year and we're gonna have a
lot of fun too you're gonna leave fired
up for 2023 and do I need to remind you
it's completely free if the economy
feels out of control you don't have to
so to register for this free live stream
go to ramsaysolutions.com
wealth to sign up that's
ramseysolutions.com wealth love it let's
do this thing all right Jade we got our
question of the day and it comes from
Nick in Wisconsin what does Nick have to
say he says I'm 22 years old and I make
81k a year before taxes as a mechanical
engineer I have 50k in my Roth IRA and
13k in my 401k very good I have no debt
of fully funded emergency fund and I'm
currently investing 15 of my earnings
into the 401K I'm wondering what your
next financial step should be save up
for a down payment on a house or
continue to invest while while the
market is low I'm concerned I might be
putting too much money away in accounts
that I can't touch until I'm 60. I love
the show and I would hope to hear back
from you soon well Nick great job what a
Rockstar yeah man you're killing the
game I'm really proud of you you're
doing just what you should be doing
um no debt excellent you know uh he
didn't say much about his oh he did say
he has a fully funded emergency okay
excellent baby step four baby step four
and wanting a house yeah he's doing a
great job I love this so if I'm you you
could kind of work this one or two ways
I think that you can just go ahead and
start doing both I think you can keep
doing your 15 I'm assuming there's some
margin there and start saving for a
house now for some reason there's not
any margin to do both you could pause
investing and go backwards to what we
would call baby step 3B save for your
down payment once you've got that done
and you've got the house then go back to
the investing but really what stood out
to me right here was the final sentence
when he said I might be putting too much
away from money uh money and accounts
that I can't touch until I'm 60. no
that's not true when it comes to
investing for retirement time is your
friend and it's so great that you're
able to start investing early that
you've actually got your life together
you know the rest of us out here we
rarely get those calls they're like okay
Dave I uh I'm upset because I put too
much money away in retirement man I wish
I could go back
if I could put you're so cute Nick's
crushing it again you can do one of two
things you could slow down investing I
don't think you need to you make 81k a
year I would set a goal for yourself and
go all right in my area in Wisconsin I
need I'm gonna get this kind of house
I'm gonna do the 15-year I need it to be
a quarter of my take-home pay yep all
right 60 Grand is my goal in two years
that's 30 grand a year that's this much
a month and you be about that business
and all of a sudden you've been
investing 15 and you're a homeowner
that's right that's right I love it
thanks for the question Nick appreciate
it let's go to the phones the number to
call is triple eight eight two five five
two two five Kane is waiting in Ohio
Kane welcome to the show
hi guys how you doing I'm doing great
how can we help
all right so I'm I'm 18 years old I'm a
senior in high school
um I've been working consistently since
I was 14 and recently I started my job
that I'm hoping to keep for a long term
and um I wanted to buy a house after I
graduate well or move to an apartment
and I was wondering what you guys
thought was a smart decision either a
house or an apartment
cool so you're you're 18 what are you
making right now with this job
um to estimate I haven't been here for a
year yet so I'm just going to estimate
it's probably anywhere between
35 and 45k a year what are you doing
I'm a mechanic wow and you're in school
as well are you are you going to need
any further education or training
uh no I uh I go to a career center and
the job I'm at now right now I'm in the
quick service department but they've
offered me a higher position right after
I graduate so I should be making more
money right after I graduate but I can't
say how much way to go man that's really
good and no debt yeah
I know that excellent trying to stay out
of it how much money do you have in the
bank
I'm currently just shy of 9 000. my guy
good job you're doing so great all right
so you I if you're talking about where
to go next uh again I don't think you
need to go buy a home tomorrow but if
you want to go rent an apartment for a
while I think it's going to give you
some dignity and make you feel like a
real adult and truthfully you're so far
ahead of most adults that you're very
mature for your age I would go rent
somewhere and if you want to get a
roommate to kind of have a buddy and
split the expenses and have more money
to save up for that future down payment
on a home you can do that I like it
right all right all right cool and then
I do have another question if that's
okay sure
um so I've been listening to the podcast
for a while and it seems like a lot of
the people who call Nick a lot more
money than I'm expecting to make so
there is a concern that maybe I'll be
struggle with in the future financially
um because all these other people are
struggling and I don't want to who's the
other people the other people have debt
the people that you're talking about
struggling half the people the majority
of the folks that are calling in are
calling in because they're drowning in
debt and you're not right now and I hope
that you never are if you make the
choice to stay out of debt live on less
than you make you got 9k saved you're
doing at this point you're doing
everything right you just need to
continue that path forward and yes
you're in your income you know it's fine
to Aspire to more income you're young
you've got plenty of time you know
you're doing this at this point in your
life who knows down the line you might
decide you want to get into something
else you know but your income is going
to come is going to go up you're 18
years old right now and as a mechanic I
mean there's so much upward trajectory
for you in that field uh who knows maybe
you'll own your own shop one day and so
yeah don't discount that but also
realize you could live off if you
continue this way you could live off of
40 and still have a great life and
Rachel Cruz and I we just released a new
episode of smart money happy hour and
it's all about the magic salary does it
exist
um what is it for happiness and success
and the takeaway I'll spoil it there is
really no magic number because we get
calls from people who make 250 Grand who
are broke and miserable oh yeah it's not
about the amount it's about how you're
managing it and we get calls from people
who make thirty five thousand dollars
and paid off 16 000 in debt and they
live a great life and they're very happy
and they're accomplishing their goals so
Kane you're gonna get there for sure
you're already well on your way and I
will be shocked if your income doesn't
continue to go up year after year and
you're making you know 85 90 000 one day
as a mechanic yeah he's got the right
idea I like the way his mind works I
like that he's thinking towards the
future I like that he's really weighing
his options I love that he stayed out of
debt he's got money saved and you know
to your point George it kind of goes
back to what you're talking about on
Smart money happy hour it's it is not
about the amount of income and it's
about how you're managing it if you're
staying out of debt look we saw uh the
Bloomberg report that came came out and
the majority of people that make 250 000
and more those are the people who are
living paycheck to paycheck it's
unbelievable so more income does not
equal uh greater wealth right we know
that well on a lot of times when you
have that kind of income you feel like
well I need to have a certain level of
status and lifestyle and so it's called
lifestyle creep yes it creeps up the
more money you make the more money you
spend and part of it is keeping that in
check and if you can make that kind of
money while still living with low
expenses killing the game and you have
margin then you have peace and you got
joy and you have options and you have
freedom and that's what this whole plan
is about it's not about getting out of
debt so we can get out of debt right
it's doing it so that so have those
kinds of options I know that's right
yeah that lifestyle creep that's that's
the killer man that'll that'll get you
because you start thinking you deserve
it I deserve well that's why our in our
millionaire study we study 10 000 of
them the top three engineer accountant
teacher yep those are are not flashy
people who are trying to impress you in
their nice cars teachers are just trying
to get through the day okay they're not
driving into the school parking lot the
Mercedes going look at me kids look how
cool I am yeah yeah and so if you
continue to live on less than you make
live on a budget stay out of debt invest
for the future the salary becomes less
and less relevant Amen to that let's go
more of your calls coming up triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Music]
show I'm George Campbell co-host of
smart money happy hour host of the fine
print entree leadership podcast joined
by my co-host Jade warshaw this hour and
we are taking your calls about life and
money at triple eight eight two five
five two two five well if you are
looking for some healthy hacks to start
the new year we've got 21 tips for you
in this weekend's edition of the Ramsey
newsletter whether you're still on track
or about to hop on do not let your
budget be the bad guy to eating better
we've got lots of tips to eating well
and staying within that food budget for
example here's some try having a snack
before you go to the store AKA don't
shop on the empty stomach been there and
maybe even swap grocery stores which can
be a very emotional decision for a lot
of people they don't want to let go of
Whole Foods snow and so if you want
these 21 tips it's completely free just
sign up for the newsletter at
ramseysolutions.com
newsletter you'll get subscribed to our
Sunday newsletter and we'll help you
keeping uh keep working towards those
New Year's goals and Jade I know you are
big on food Plus on a budget George we
all know food is the biggest grocery
it's the biggest budget Buster and it's
the easiest area to justify oh yeah and
I mean and there's so many ways that
they get you right you're going down the
aisles I know for me it's when I see a
new product like if it's kind of like in
the realm of like I I love dried fruits
so like when they come out with a new
like I love dried pineapple do they have
new fruits I've never heard of well like
they'll put it out in a different way
like then they came out one with one
that had like like chili seasoning on it
and I was like oh I gotta try it no I I
don't want to say this George I'm a
Whole Foods shopper
guys this is mind-blowing because Jade
is the most like I'm gonna do this on a
budget and Be Frugal bro and there she
is got it on lock I'm telling you I know
how to do it I have it unlocked if you
haven't visited my social media you
should pop over there because I've got
like food tips how to shop on a budget
like I know you do too we we we got this
unlocked George the people need to come
see this but I mean
for me I always say I I can shop at
Whole Foods because I'm I'm meatless I
don't I don't buy the most expensive
item in the store which is the half of
America they're like Jade without meat
what is life look do I look like I'm at
a lack of protein man cannot live on
bread alone your girl your girl's got
enough that's the tagline for Slim Jims
I think at this point no that's it's not
just to a Slim Jim it's in the Bible
what are we talking about here's my
thing with with food Jade I will like do
the math on like the per serving because
some things you're like oh that's like
eight bucks a meal but if we get this
one it's three bucks yeah well I mean we
were just talking about this before the
break I feel like the biggest uh the
ones that get you the worst on that is
like the pre-packaged items right like
if you buy the oatmeal and it's like
pre-second sectioned off in the little
packet you're paying so much you're
getting ripped off per ounce just buy
the big old thing a Quaker Oats in my
case get the organic one please and put
your own brown sugar in there it's gonna
be cheaper it's gonna be healthier and
you're going to get more per
Jade my viral uh post that on on reels
and Tick Tock and all that was about how
a meal at home is four bucks average
meal out is 13 and it's cheaper to eat
at home and I got hammered in the
comments and here was the number one
comment oh is my time not worth anything
all that time cooking and doing the
dishes I'm I'm worth too much per hour
to be doing all of those menial tasks
when someone else could do it for me do
y'all want this money or not clearly not
they're like that's the only question
I'm making 20 bucks an hour so my time
is worth more than me sitting at home
cooking and cleaning I mean here's the
thing there's a time to go to a
restaurant
sure my job broke when you're not broke
budget for it go to a restaurant but if
you're out here and baby step two if you
are broke if you've got tons of debt
hanging around your neck cook at home
trust me when Sam and I were getting out
of debt I learned and this was a big
motivator for me because we weren't
eating in a lot of restaurants I learned
to cook at home and I learned to make
bomb food because I was not about to be
putting all of my money to Sallie Mae
depressed about that no way was I going
to sit down and eat just a terrible meal
of ramen noodles I was going to learn
how to make beans and rice and lentils
and tofu and all this stuff tastes
delicious and my husband is sitting out
there behind the glass and he's shaking
his head because he knows mama can cook
we made sure that we were eating right
and you can too that's the other things
people go well Jade I'm a terrible cook
so I'm just gonna eat out every day you
can learn
I I believe you can learn I believe that
God created seasonings for the people
preach okay you get you some garlic
powder for sure salt and I want to see
this this is the sign right here George
if you can't see the flex of seasoning
in the food it's not enough it's not
seasoned bro it is not that's your life
if you put me an egg if you fry an egg
George and you put it in front of me and
it's just a white and a yolk and I don't
see any flecks of seasoning no thanks
Tom Hanks no thanks thanks I love it
well lots of tips there
ramseysolutions.com newsletter for 21
more shred your own cheese that was my
last one all right Kaylee got to hear
that for free she's waiting on the line
in Indianapolis Kaylee how are you
I'm good how are you guys doing great
how can we help today
our friend Rachel it's so good
thank you um okay so I have been a long
time listener
um I recently had some stuff happen that
I was like oh my gosh I have to get my
life together I need to get my money
figured out
um so I'd rather tell the Money Makeover
been listening to the podcast everything
I can get my hands on I'm trying to
figure out how
you stay super motivated but also don't
get crushed with the weight of oh my
gosh I am in a terrible situation
because I'm in between the two right now
wow well tell us about your situation
what how much debt do you have and
what's your income
um I have about 12 000 and a couple
credit cards and a personal loan and
then I've got sixty thousand dollars in
student loans
um my income is only 30 a year which I
know the first thing you guys are going
to say is get your income up I am
actively working on that it's in the
process of going up but right now that's
where I'm at okay
um trying to figure out you know looking
for stuff to sell I've been cutting
subscription or yeah subscriptions
trying to figure out how to not have to
sell my kids or my kidney on the black
market how many kids do you have
I have two and I got Financial Peace
Junior for my nine-year-old for
Christmas and we've been doing that
together because I'm like she I don't
want her to have to go through
everything okay I've gone through with
all these dumb decisions I want her to
be smart before that's a great why are
you a single mom yeah
um I have a boyfriend that I live with
um he's not as on board with it as I am
but we don't have combined finances so I
was just like
whatever all right this is Kaylee's
Journey my girls all right I love this
Kaylee number one
I I want to encourage you right now
because you said something and the
minute you said it my my heart started
bursting for you because you were like
man you were listing out your debt and
you said then the worst thing is I my
income is only 30k
can I tell you I just got to tell you
this because I hope that it gives you
hope when I started my debt-free journey
with my husband our income was 30k
but we had we had 460 000.
okay so I want this is what I want you
to come away with this it's been done
and it can be done and your income is
not going to stay at 30k dear you're
gonna you're gonna work hard you're
gonna move what what is your what is
your uh job at this time
um I'm a customer customer service
representative but I did just get my
bachelor's in November so I'm working
with a career counselor at my former
College to
um get a job I'm in the process of
getting like a work from home freelance
editing job to supplement my income
um so I'm working on upping my income
but what was your degree wasn't there
yet
um Business and Professional studies
cool okay so income you're working on
the income do we have so let's let's
talk about the baby steps right George
let's just make sure you understand the
plan because you've read The Total Money
Makeover do you have baby step one in
place currently
I do not that's what I'm working on okay
how close are you
I literally just like a week ago decided
oh we need to get my life together
that's all right that's all right so
we're we're are you the job you're doing
right now customer service is there any
time to get a second like some second
income coming in because like you said
you're just looking for ways to get this
money right
yes and that's why I'm getting ready to
start the like the freelancing editing
job it's great let's get that five
dollars an hour great let's get a second
side hustle going let's get a third side
hustle going you're working 80 hours a
week hey put that boyfriend to work
because I know he's not sitting up in
that apartment freeloading he better be
paying okay I do not want you floating
anybody else you got two kids you're a
single mom I want you to get baby step
one you're gonna be able to do baby step
two 30k that is not where you're
stopping you're gonna get this debt paid
off I know you can do it okay we're
gonna send you Financial Peace
University for one year to walk
alongside you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
comes from first Thessalonians 5 16-18
Rejoice always pray continually give
thanks in all circumstances for this is
God's will for you in Christ Jesus
Cicero said a thankful heart is not only
the greatest virtue but the parent of
all the other virtues
that's good I like it good stuff there
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five I'm George
Campbell joined by Jade warshaw this
hour Abby is in Rochester Minnesota Abby
welcome to the show
hi I'm so excited we're excited to talk
to you what's going on
alrighty
um so
um me and my boyfriend you know we work
for a
company currently past few months have
been rough draining working like 55 60
hours a week there's no time for
personal life family time really taking
a toll but we recently gotten some hot
water just because we didn't disclose
this relationship as soon as they would
have liked
um so just kind of financially and just
for the sake of our relationship I'm
just kind of in a point where I don't
know if it would be smart for me to just
kind of walk away from that job and try
to find something else that's gonna just
make us a whole lot happier do you like
the job I mean aside from the dating
thing on this guy would you leave
anyways
um so it's always been kind of a
question like oh we could like I could
believe it it's it's definitely been a
lot more draining the past few months so
it's just a job a lot of Joy are you
getting overtime for these extra hours
uh no I'm salary
yeah I'd find something where they value
your time and you go I'm working my 40
hours that's what I'm paid for is he
doing the same is he also working 60
hours and he's frustrated too
yep it sounds like the the dating thing
is like a sidebar to the overarching
issue it sounds like for both of you
this is just a job it sounds like you're
you're going there you're doing the
thing but you're not as Ken would say it
doesn't sound like you have the juice
you know does he need to go too I'm like
can you both go get different jobs
elsewhere
um
I I think so I mean it's just kind of
scary you know
walking away from a place that's paying
me so much and benefits and stuff and
what's the salary taking a chance
uh my salary is 78.
and what's he making
about 84. are they similar roles
oh yeah
can you you know have you done any
research to find out you know if there's
anything out there that interests you or
you know I think it's time to start
asking some questions is basically what
I'm saying it's time to start asking is
there a better role out there is this
ultimately what I want to be doing am I
in the area that I want to be in am I
open to moving start start dreaming a
little bit start asking some questions
and I think you know I think that we
should set her up with Ken's book
paycheck to purpose yes because I think
that you guys need to just I it might
just be the you're frustrated in this
season but the vibe I'm getting is that
you're not happy in this job like at all
and it was just the straw that broke the
camera's back with the HR situation and
and you know what here's the thing with
salary salary is great it's great when
you are earning a a wage that that you
like you know in this case you're like
man I'm earning a lot of money it's hard
to walk away from that but you got to be
happy you're spending so much of your
time there it's your job your work is
way more than what you earn all right
you got to feel like you're being
challenged you got to feel like you're
doing work that matters you got to feel
like let me tell you something every day
I come into work I'm excited
and even before I came to Ramsey the job
I had worked before that when I go into
work if you're not excited about what
you do if it doesn't fire you up if
you're not feeling like yes I get to do
this every day it's time to start
thinking it's start time to start
dreaming
yeah so you've got your homework Abby
number one we're gonna send you from
paycheck to purpose you and your
boyfriend can read that but number two
start doing your homework and start
applying places and see what's out there
because I think right now in your head
you're kind of comfortable it's safe
it's a good job it's not the best but
they're overworking you but you don't
think you're worth 78 000 elsewhere and
I think that is the biggest myth of all
yeah you've got something to offer if
you're making it now you can make it
again and make it and then some even if
you took a slight pay cut and started
working 40 hours a week that's still a
better deal because you got 20 hours of
your life back so I think you know what
to do but it's it's scary when you've
been at a place for a long time and
you're going I gotta do this gotta clean
up the resume which by the way Ken's got
some great resources at Ken coleman.com
resume templates his get clear
assessment for anyone listening out
there who's feeling the same way Abby is
going there's got to be something else
out there yeah because people don't hate
the idea of work they really just hate
their jobs and they hate their companies
and they hate their toxic leaders and
that stuff can be fixed that's true but
like you said George it's tough to step
out you have to ask yourself is it more
uncomfortable for me to stay in that
position or is it more uncomfortable you
know you've got to be willing to step
out and it's not easy but it will it can
it can repay in Spades thanks for the
question Abby Evan joined us joins us up
next in Kokomo Indiana Evan I didn't
know there was a Kokomo Indiana now I'm
really happy about it
well yeah there you go thank you guys so
much how you doing
I'm doing well how are you good good
what's your question
I'll get right to it um so I was
fortunate enough to receive a full ride
scholarship for my undergraduate
education sweet
but I had uh
very wise parents who saved about 25 000
for me on a 529 and I don't plan to
pursue any uh higher level of Education
after I graduate uh next spring and uh
I don't know what to do with that money
or how to get it out uh considering I
believe it's a 10 penalty plus capital
gains tax
to pull that out so I didn't know what
my options were moving forward
how old are you
I am 20 years old all right cool cool
and you're single I assume
not so long but uh yes that's exciting
okay so there are there are a lot of
options and there are some new rulings
as well which is cool with the 529 plan
that just came out for I think 2024.
it's going to be applicable where you
can actually transfer 529 funds into a
retirement account that's right and
that's what I was thinking this money is
still going to serve you it's just not
going to serve you in the way
that it was initially intended to which
is a good thing okay and beyond that I
mean you're you're probably going to
have kids one day right
sure and so you could use that towards
your child's future needs you can change
the beneficiary on there that's right
do you have any student loans or do you
go to completely debt right now
uh it's completely debt free okay
awesome so that would be my plan is
right now I would just hang on to it and
as the law change happens and you're
able to transfer that into a retirement
account that's a great option or if
you're like hey I'm getting married
we're gonna have kids I can just
transfer this These funds to my kid
that's right because you can it's very
loose you could even transfer that make
the beneficiary uh niece a nephew a
cousin I mean the the language is very
loose which is great does it go over
would it go over to a spouse
oh why it's a good question I believe I
think it does I have to look into the uh
the fine print there yeah the good thing
is you know you your your parents set
this this money aside for for you and it
has the potential to really serve in a
generational way you know if it wasn't
just for you you know you have the
ability to pass it on to your kids it
can go into retirement later on I think
that's amazing that's exciting and a fun
fact for those that get scholarships
like well this stinks I saved all this
money and I got a scholarship well you
can take out that amount from the 529
tax-free against the scholarship so
that's a really cool thing for those
that have that situation I love that
how's that sound Evan
it's exciting it's a lot more clarity
than I had when I told him to have man
way to go it's a great problem to have I
graduated debt free and now I got money
sitting in the 529. okay that's
fantastic and we found out that Kokomo
is a real place The Beach Boys
gosh they love it I don't know that they
were thinking about Indiana at the time
you don't think that they wanted us to
vacation in Kokomo Indiana I'm sure it's
a lovely place truly
I love it they said it's where we want
to go well Jay there was a theme in
today's show and that is young people
doing really smart things yes I I've
been feeling that theme all week long I
feel invigorated
and you know what it stems from is the
parents yes so years ago the parents got
a hold of the Ramsay plan or common
sense wisdom and went hey what if we
just stayed out of debt and were able to
pay for our kids college and had money
in the bank
and all of a sudden you create
generational change okay okay by doing
that and now we're getting 15 year olds
19 year olds calling in saying hey I
have no debt and a pile of money what do
I do I'm like this is the best problem
to have we love to see it keep guys keep
calling in this is what it's all about
changing your family tree changing your
legacy right here on the Ramsay show my
thanks to my co-host Jade warshaw all
the folks in the booth and you America
thanks for tuning in until next time
spend wisely save intentionally and give
generously
[Music]
foreign
do you love a good day brand want to see
the latest Ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the Ramsay show on YouTube go watch
And subscribe to the Ramsay show channel
on YouTube
[Music]